this is a production of cornell
university
and so i'm really interested in how we
can aid
breeding efforts across a wide range of
crop species
in order to combat malnutrition
and really aid the ability to get a
wider variety of food sources in our
diets
and so one way that we can think of how
to aid these breeding efforts is by
transferring knowledge and so the
question is how can we
transfer lessons learned from
well-studied species like maize
and arabidopsis and apply that knowledge
to a wide number of crops and orphan
crops
and so one of the mechanisms that we can
use to facilitate this net
uh transfer of knowledge is by thinking
of mechanisms that are conserved
across long evolutionary time scales
and so one of the mechanisms that's
conserved across long evolutionary time
scales is transcription factor binding
and what i'm showing here is a very
simplistic tree but what i want you to
take away from it is
in red is what i'm showing the emergence
of
new transcription factor families and so
there are a number of transcription
factor families that predate
the origin of plants and also
there are a number of plant
transcription plant-specific
transcription factor families that
predate angiosperms
and so we expect a lot of their binding
motifs to be conserved
in many of these plant species
and so this is the problem that a former
member of the lab catherine mejiaguera
explicitly tried to look at and so what
she did was she trained
some sequence models on to predict
whether a tf is bound to a specific dna
sequence
and when she looks at the motifs that
are learned by these models
and clusters them they follow the
expected phylogeny of the transcription
factor families that she sampled
so this suggests that the models are
really learning uh the biologically
relevant motifs
and so what she did then was compared
the
learned motifs against the orthologs in
arabidopsis and saw that about 60
of these binding motifs are conserved
between the two species
and so what i wanted to do to follow up
on this was take catherine's model
architecture and train them in
arabidopsis-specific tf
and so i used i predicted in arabidopsis
and so what i want you to focus on here
is the area
the relative area under these curves
here and so the black line shows the
within species model performance
then when i take that same model and
attempt to predict an orthologous tf and
maize
i get a reduction in performance but
still above the baseline random
classifier shown in
the gray dashed line the next when i
take
uh arabidopsis and maize sequence and
attempt to predict
tf binding in arabidopsis or maze i see
that this across species model does
almost as well as the within species
model
despite very different genomic contexts
between these two species
now unfortunately transcription factor
binding especially chip
expensive and complicated to assay and
so i was wondering if there was an
alternative way that we can really get
at this transcription factor binding
motif question
uh in a more easily accessible manner
and so we know that open chromatin
regions in the genome are really where
these functional
uh transcription factor binding motifs
are concentrated
and so here i'm just showing a very
simple schematic of an open chromatin
region flanked by the closed chromatin
wrapped around the histones and
various transcription factors bound in
different orientations
uh in the sequence
and so the question becomes can we
transfer
these open chromatin sequences across
angiosperms but also are they
even relevant for breeding purposes and
that's one of the questions that this
2016 study in may is attempted to
address
and so what they found is that open
chromatin regions
explain about 40 percent of the
phenotypic variants in a number of
traits
in two maize populations suggesting that
really these open chromatin regions do
help capture some of the non-genetic
functional space
and so the next question becomes can we
well so i've shown that maize
and arabidopsis you can transfer
transcription factor binding between the
two
then can we also transfer chromatin
accessibility
and then the next question becomes what
kind of models would be used to do that
and so one of the models that i've
already introduced in a previous seminar
is convolutional neural networks and so
cnns are really well suited for this
kind of
open chromatin prediction because
they're designed to
learn the spatial dependencies and
relationships between motifs or patterns
in a sequence and this is exactly like
we'd expect the transcription factor
binding motifs to be arranged in the
open chromatin like i showed in the left
and so another important point here is
that not only do these
cnns learn the presence and absence
relationship between tfs and chromatin
accessibility
but more importantly the co-presence and
the co-presence of maybe
larger tf modules because since tf
binding sites are so short and
degenerate they tend to occur just by
chance throughout the genome and it's
really critical that
we can precisely identify these open
chromatin regions by their context
and not just single motifs
and so how i train this convolutional
neural network was using an excellent
leaf ataxia data set from 13 angiosperm
species
that was published last year by bob
schmidt's group over at the university
of georgia
and so what i did was i trained this cnn
in 26 different configurations
13 of which were within species model
where i took one species
split the genomic regions into
training and test sets and then
evaluated the model in the test set and
then i also trained 13 across species
models
where i took one test species of the
angiosperms
trained in the genomic regions of the
other 12
and tried to predict chromatin
accessibility in the 13th species
so just a very quick overview of how the
data looks the atex c
causes basically a reed pile up in these
open chromatin regions
and you can run an algorithm that's
known as a peak collar to binarize that
output
and denoise the open chromatin region
predictions
and then what you can do is then
randomly sample a group of closed
chromatin regions from
the genome so very quickly an example
for a specific sequence or
specific species let's say arabidopsis
the within species model very
straightforward you just split the
genomic regions and
train in the training set and then test
in your test set
and then the cross species model is
let's say we're testing an arabidopsis
we would then train
in the other 12 species and attempt to
predict in arabidopsis like this
and so here is what the example
performance would look like for the
arabidopsis within species in a
cross-species model
we see the performances on the x-axis
from zero to one
and so when i do the results across all
the angiosperm species i've sampled
we see that despite there being a
variability in performance across the
species they're all doing
much much better than a random baseline
classifier shown in the gray dash or the
black dash line
and then when we show the cross species
model performance
pretty much in every species we see that
the cross species model performance
is very equivalent to the within species
model performance
and what this suggests is that without
seeing any open chromatin data from a
given species we are still able to
utilize
angiosperm open chromatin data to
accurately and precisely predict
the open chromatin in that unobserved
species
and so to dive a little deeper into
these results i want to show you two
precision recall plots from my cross
species models
so on the left we see arabidopsis
daliana as the test set and what i want
you to take away from this
is that essentially about 55 of my open
chromatin regions
in arabidopsis the model is able to
precisely predict them before it starts
to begin making mistakes
and so also in asparagus which the model
does relatively
worse on we're still able to predict
about 20 percent of the open chromatin
regions as open
precisely before we start to make
mistakes and so what this suggests is
that there's a
seems to be a subset of open chromatin
regions
that we're really precisely able to
identify and these might be a good
starting point
while we're still trying to figure out
how to predict the the other percentages
and one other interesting phenomenon
that we see in asparagus and a few other
species
is this rapid drop-off in precision so
essentially what this says is there is a
subset of open
uh closed chromatin regions in the
a-taxi that the model is highly
confidently
predicting as open which suggests to me
there may be
some uh maybe due to lower coverage and
the a-tac
seeks some truly open regions that were
marked as closed
and so this really gets at the whole
idea that your model can only be
evaluated as good as your test set is
and so in summary um shown a bit that
transcription factor binding can be
predicted across angiosperms
but is unfortunately expensive and
complicated the assay
and so the open chromatin also contains
transcription factor binding sites and
therefore
overlap our non-genetic functional sites
and so therefore cnns can predict uh i
show that cnns can predict chromatin
accessibility across long evolutionary
distances with high accuracy
and a couple more things i want to
follow up on is how well do these leaf
train models do
in other tissues as well as are these
predicted regions enriched in geowas
hits and other signals of regulatory
regions
and so i'd like to finally acknowledge
my committee at buckler amy williams and
eric richards for their guidance
catherine mejiaguera who has been like
an unofficial fourth committee member
and has really been who i'm basing a lot
of this work on them off of
as well as the buckler lab for their
excellent discussions on this project
and of course my funding sources
i'd be happy to take any questions thank
you
thank you so much for that talk travis
uh lots of clap em emojis
um if anybody has any questions they can
either add them oh i think mike gore has
some questions if you can see them in
the chat
sure let me see is there a need to
control for evolutionary relatedness
from protecting across species or is
that what is leveraged
yeah that's a great question mike and uh
we talked about this in the lab a bit
and
i'm really leaning towards the second
part of that question
there is revolutionary relationship
between uh these
open chromatin regions um and it's
really a tough call because that's
exactly what we're trying to expect to
leverage
so the question becomes how can we make
sure these models are learning
for example transcription factor binding
rather than
a non-informative but evolutionary
related sequence
and then two are the shared open
chromatin regions overlapping with
conserved non-coding regions
i haven't looked at this yet but that's
a question i definitely want to follow
up on
um travis just to follow on what what
mike was asking
have you have you tried schemes like
where you if you're predicting a monocot
you just use the monocots you don't
bother with the
dicots yeah and and how does that impact
performance yeah so that's an
interesting question because i did do
that initially i haven't
i haven't shown the results here and
it does show essentially what you expect
in that
for most of the species performance
decreases a bit
slightly when you go from a monocot
based model
to an angiosperm based model there's
some very
strange signal for some species like we
saw poplar got very
was very good with a die-cut model but
when you bring it out to the angiosperms
it does poorly so
i'd say generally performance lowers a
little bit but not
significantly or not very much
we have another question how to explain
the lower performance in maize compared
to rice
yeah i think i'll answer that question
by just sort of explaining
why i think there's some variability
between species and
ed sort of gets at that point a bit in
that there is an uneven
uh depth of data between these species
and so
not only is the data quality a bit
variable between species and we can
see that by looking at the within
species models are also performing
poorly so a combination of uneven
data quality across the species maybe
some assembly
issues some possible tissue mismatching
so there are a number of things that
could go into that
i think that wraps up our time but we
can give a final
round of applause to all of our speakers
today uh
thank you all for attending make sure to
fill out that
feedback form and tune back in
friday at 2 30 for four more great talks
thanks
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu